je suis heureux dans le prolongement des
échanges très riches que nous avons vu
en commission de présenter à votre haute
assemblée le projet de loi de
ratification de l'ordonnancé du 11
septembre 2019 porte en partie
législative du code de la justice pénale
des mineurs
la loi final tout particulièrement
lorsqu'elle concerne les mineurs suscite
souvent des débats parfois excessif
toujours légitimes surtout lorsqu'ils
permettent de construire un consensus
dans notre société celui d'améliorer le
sort de nos enfants est le mieux
protéger la société dans son ensemble
cette réforme est particulièrement
attendu ceux-ci sierre de débattre avec
vous d'un texte aussi largement
concertée avec tous les acteurs de la
justice des mineurs
vous le savez il avait plus été enrichie
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale est désormais par votre
commission des lois je tiens d'ailleurs
ici à saluer le travail constructif de
votre rapporteur madame la sénatrice
canayer qui a pointé justement très
justement devrais je dire un certain
nombre d'enjeux sur lesquels bien sûr je
reviendrai je les ai déjà dit lors de
mon audition et je voudrais insister
cette réforme n'est en rien une
construction at-il mais le fruit de plus
de dix ans de consultations
ce sont quatre gars de des shows et
presqu'autant de majorité qui ont
préparé ce travail de codification et de
planification de notre droit le sénat il
ya d'ailleurs
largement contribué avec par exemple le
rapport du sénateur amiel sur les
mineurs jean ferme est rendu en 2018
longuement mûri cette réforme en est
d'autant plus équilibré j'ai la
certitude qu'elle parvient à répondre
aux attentes des français
améliorer la justice pénal applicable
aux mineurs délinquants
tout en renforçant les principes
fondamentaux de l'ordonnancé de 1945 la
primauté de l'éducatif l'atténuation de
la peine
la spécialisation des acteurs
permettez-moi en quelques mots de
revenir sur les grands apports de ce
texte il consacre tout d'abord une
justice des mineurs plus efficace et
plus lisible parce que désormais
prévisible pour tous la phase judiciaire
éducative interviendra plus vite dans un
cadre procédural clarifier et simplifier
la suppression de la phase de mise en
examen devant le juge des enfants
avec la généralisation de la procédure
de césure assure enfin une réponse
éducative rapide au plus près du passage
à l'acte
gage essentiel de la rente tivité et de
l'efficacité de la justice des mineurs
j'ai su ce trop longue perd toutes ses
vertus pédagogiques
rappelons la procédure
le mineur est convoqué à une première
audience de culpabilité dans un délai
compris entre dix jours et trois mois
cette première audience et est cruciale
car elle permet d statuer sur la
culpabilité du mineur dans un délai
raisonnable adapté à la particularité de
son âge alors qu'aujourd'hui ce délai
est de 18 mois en moyenne
la seconde audience vivante au prononcé
de la sanction mesures éducatives ou
peine intervient dans un délai compris
entre six à neuf mois elles clôturent
une période de mise à l'épreuve
éducative le temps éducatif n'est pas
raccourci c'est le temps judiciaire qui
est encadré la mesure éducative unique
s'inscrit dans un continuum et elle peut
d'ailleurs se poursuivre au delà de la
majorité jusqu'au 21 nom du jeune la
mise à l'épreuve éducative et modulable
selon la situation du mineur et son
l'évolution avec des modules insertion
réparation placement
chantez vous retrouvez ici toutes les
composantes de la mission menée par les
éducateurs de la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse
il dispose désormais d'un cadre
d'intervention clarifier et flexible la
primauté de l'éducatif est ainsi garanti
grâce à une réponse éducative cohérente
encadrée par des délais de procédure
l'effectivité
de la réponse éducative permet de
réduire le recours à la détention
provisoire qui concerne actuellement
environ 80 %
80% des mineurs détenus
les jugements rapides en audience et
nick reste exceptionnel est soumis à une
appréciation individualisé des
procureurs spécialisés qui doivent
concilier la gravité des faits reprochés
et bien sûr la personnalité du mineur
ces garde-fous sont nombreux et le juge
saisi garde la possibilité de revenir
aux principes de la césure ainsi l'une
grands équilibres sont non seulement
maintenues mais ils sont renforcés
je tiens également à valoriser qui
signent conséquence essentielle et
primordiale de la réforme la meilleure
prise en charge des victimes qui seront
mieux informés et mieux associer à
toutes les étapes de la procédure
je souhaiterais ensuite revenir sur
certaines des modifications apportées
par votre commission en commençant par
celle touchante au fond du droit avant
d'en venir à la question indissociable
de l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme à
ce titre trois points ne semble devoir
être évoquée certains appelant une
convergence d'autres la prolongation des
débats la suppression par la commission
de l'intervention du juge des libertés
et de la détention
introduite à juste titre lors de
l'examen du texte à l'assemblée
nationale ne peut qu'affaiblir
l'exigence d'impartialité qui doit
trouver à s'appliquer également aux
mineurs comme c'est déjà le cas pour les
majeurs
j'attire
votre attention sur les difficultés
soulevées en pratique par l'intervention
de plusieurs juges des enfants prévue
par votre commission notamment au sein
des petites juridictions dans lesquelles
il n'y en a souvent qu'un seul c'est
pour ces raisons tant juridique que
pratique que le gouvernement vous
propose par amendement de garantir
l'impartialité de la justice des mineurs
au stade de la mise en examen en
prévoyant l'intervention du juge des
libertés et de la détention sans que
cela remette d'une quelconque manière
la continuité des six vie des mineurs
par le juge des enfants
la commission des lois est revenu sur
les compétences
pourtant bien établie et qui ne soulève
aucune difficulté juridique du tribunal
de police pour les contraventions de
faible intensité des quatre premières
classes
or lançant les acteurs de terrain sont
unanimes pour estimer que l'intervention
d'un juge des enfants spécialisés de
rester dédié aux cinq filles éducative
de long terme
la confusion des procédures ne peut que
nuire à la lisibilité de la justice des
mineurs est donc à son efficacité
j'ai en revanche était convaincu par la
proposition de votre commission visant à
renforcer la force normes at il de la
définition du discernement désormais un
cerf désormais insérer pardonnez moi
dans la partie législative
je souscris à l'objectif poursuivi tout
en suggérant en terme d'écriture d'y
intégrer les notions de compréhension et
de volonté qui sont plus jeunes
objectivables que celle de maturité nous
pouvons ici nous référer à la définition
adoptée par la cour de cassation
faisant référence à la compréhension de
la procédure
de la procédure pénale par le mineur il
nous faut enfin évoqué la question de
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme qui
est tout à la fois lié à la question des
moyens mais aussi à l'importance des
modifications apportées au texte lors
des débats parlementaires en termes de
moyens je veux souligner une fois de
plus que le gouvernement s'est employé
depuis de nombreux mois à donner à
toutes les parties prenantes les moyens
indispensables à la bonne mise en oeuvre
de la réforme
c'est ainsi que des moyens humains
supplémentaires conséquents ont été
attribués aux juridictions et aux
services de protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse
deux cent cinquante deux emplois
nouveaux créés jusqu'en 2022
quatre-vingt six éducateurs recruté dans
le cadre des budgets alloués à la
justice de proximité et près de soixante
douze magistrats recruté en 2020 dont 24
juge pour enfants l'inspection générale
de la justice a également été missionné
pour favoriser l'adaptation dès
pratiques professionnelles et apporter
un appui déterminant aux juridictions
les plus en difficulté et je tiens à
saluer ici la mobilisation
exceptionnelle des acteurs de terrain
pour s'approprier cette réforme au plus
vite
en effet de très nombreuses
concertations locales ont été menées
afin de parvenir à une appropriation de
la réforme dans les meilleurs délais
enfin les efforts conjugués des
juridictions malgré la crise sanitaire
ont permis l'apurement d'une partie des
stocks
pardon pour ce terme au niveau
capitalistique mais c'est le terme
utilisé grâce à la création d'audience
supplémentaire et à la réorientation des
dossiers les plus anciens aujourd'hui la
grande majorité
juridiction est désormais prête à
intégrer la nouvelle procédure
je vous ai dit en commission seulement
une dizaine d'entre elles se trouvent en
difficulté et bénéficient à ce titre
d'un appui renforcé mais mais l'entrée
en vigueur dépend aussi de la nature et
de l'importance des modifications
introduites par le législateur au texte
de l'ordonance comme aux aléas liés au
contexte de la crise sanitaire
quel est le dernier état de la situation
à contexte sanitaire a changé et vous
savez à quel point il peut encore
évoluer dans les semaines à venir
et au regard des derniers éléments
communiqués par mes services
seule la modification substantielle liés
à l'intervention du jld dans la
procédure conduite à des adaptations
informatique et opérationnels tels qu'un
temps supplémentaire de préparation
peut-être nécessaire comme j'ai bon
espoir que nous discutions permettre
comme je voulais indiqué à l'instant la
réintroduction des dispositions
relatives au jld et dans un esprit de
dialogue constructif et le cohérence le
gouvernement prend acte du report de la
date d'entrée en vigueur votée par votre
commission
je souhaiterais conclure mon propos en
nous réjouissant des conditions dans
lesquelles nous allons débattre avec
l'espoir de converger sur un certain
nombre de sujets pour ne pas dire sur la
quasi totalité
vous l'aurez compris cette réforme
représente aujourd'hui est une
formidable occasion de démontrer notre
capacité à mieux protéger la société
dans son ensemble tout en améliorant
l'adéquation de la réponse pénale à la
situation si particulière des mineurs
c'est cet espoir que je souhaite
aujourd'hui portèrent avec vous la
justice n'est jamais aussi grande
que lorsqu'elle se préoccupe du sort le
plus petit merci la parole et la madame
agnès canayer rapporteur de la
commission des lois et pour dix minutes
leur collègue madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la modernisation de la justice pénale
des mineurs est une réforme attendue
et là nous sommes d'accord le constat
est partagé l'ordonnancé du 2 février
1945 39 fois modifié a perdu de sa
cohérence et son efficacité
la sédimentation des réformes
législatives a rendu ce texte peu
lisible pour les juristes et peu
compréhensibles pour les mineures mais
surtout l' ordonnance de 1945 ne permet
plus de répondre aux exigences du
respect des droits de l'enfant et de
l'efficacité de la lutte contre la
délinquance des mineurs deux chiffres
traduisent l'épuisement de relance de 45
18 mois en moyenne pour la justice
pénale des mineurs pour juger et comme
60% des auteurs ont entre 16 et 18 ans
la sanction arrive souvent après la
majorité et 80% des mineurs emprisonnés
sont en détention provisoire
vous nous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre ce chiffre parle de lui-même
l' ordonnance du 11 septembre 2019
pourtant partie législative du code de
la justice pénale des mineurs dont nous
examinons aujourd'hui le projet de loi
de ratification répond clairement à cet
ambitieux objectif de modernisation de
la justice pénale des mineurs
mais malheureusement a pris une route
sinueuse qui impose l'allongement du
chemin pour atteindre le but
les innovations apportées par le nouveau
code de justice pénale des mineurs des
mineurs sont avant tout procédurale et
appelle mes chers collègues
leur appréciation nous pouvons donc
regretter à ce stade le manque
d'ambition de la réforme
l'acte manqué d'un véritable code des
mineurs réformant à la fois l'enfance
délinquante mais aussi l'enfance en
danger
malheureusement l'enfant délinquant est
trop souvent un enfant victime de
carence éducative de parents absents du
manque de repères éducatifs
je me félicite des amendements de ma
collègue valérie boyer qui tendent à
mieux responsabiliser les parents
mais nous pouvons aussi nous satisfaire
que le projet reprennent les grands
principes de l'ordonnancé de 45
l'atténuation de la responsabilité en
fonction de l'âge la primauté de
l'éducatif sur le répressif et la
spécialisation des juridictions
principes fondamentaux
il constitue le socle de la justice
pénale des mineurs
une justice adaptée à un public plus
vulnérables la spécialisation de
l'ensemble des magistrats qui
interviennent auprès des mineurs et la
base d'une justice familiariser aux
questions éducatives indissociable de la
répression des mineurs c'est pourquoi la
commission des lois du sénat a souhaité
appliquer ce principe dans son
intégralité
elle a décidé vous l'avez dit que
supprimer le recours au tribunal de
police pour les contraventions des
quatre premières classes
le juge des enfants en tant que
magistrat spécialisé doit avoir une
vision globale sur l'ensemble des
infractions commises par le mineur même
les plus modestes pour agir le plus tôt
possible
c'est l'esprit même du code de la
justice pénale des mineurs de même
l'introduction du juge de la liberté et
de la détention par les députés pour
statuer sur la détention provisoire des
mineurs incarcérés nous paraît une
atteinte inutile au principe de
spécialisation des juridictions des
mineurs certes ce dispositif vise à
mieux répondre à l'injection du conseil
constitutionnel relative à
l'impartialité du juge cependant nous
considérons que la conciliation des
principes d'impartialité et de
spécialisation sera plus équilibrée si
le contentieux de la liberté de la
détention est confiée à un juge des
enfants
autre que celui qui statuera sur la
culpabilité ou à défaut un magistrat
désigné par le président du tribunal
judiciaire en raison de son expérience
sur les questions de l'enfance
c'est tout le sens de l'amendement
adopté ans
mission la spécialisation des jld ne
sera en fait que de façade
ils sont moins nombreux que les juges
des enfants dans les petites
juridictions et l'habilitation de tous
les jmt reviendra à effacer le principe
de spécialisation
par ailleurs des juges la liberté la
détention seront accaparés par le
contentieux de la dignité en prison au
détriment du contentieux des mineurs
délinquants
enfin concernant les principes cardinaux
l'ordonance de 2019 fixe flash prive au
pivot de la présomption discernement à
13 ans tous mineurs de moins de 13 ans
est présumé ne pas être capable de
discernement et ceux d'au moins 13 le
son ce principe nouveau appel trois
remarques sur l'âge
il répond aux attentes de l'article 40
de la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant ratifiée par la
france n'existe pas aujourd'hui de
consensus sur l'âge pivot du
discernement du mineur l'âge de 13 ans
est lui par contre connu dans le droit
positif
de plus l'introduction d'une la
présomption simple et plus protectrice
du mineur et de sa victime
elle oblige le juge à se poser la
question de sa capacité de discernement
si l'auteur a moins de 13 ans et que le
juge prouve qu'il est capable de
discernement les poursuites pourront
être engagés comme dans la triste
affaire de la petite eva elle est a
contrario la présence options simples
pardon permet la souplesse de
l'adaptation à la maturité du mineur ce
que ne permet pas de déceler la date
d'anniversaire le discernement est
défini dans le code pénal mais les
critères retenus sont avant tout les
troubles psychiques et neuropsychiques
insuffisant pour les mineures la cour de
cassation à une jurisprudence constante
il nous paraissait important que cette
définition puissent s'intégrer dans la
partie législative
c'est l'occasion de l'intégrer dans ce
nouveau code pénal de la justice des
mineurs plus moderne
cette définition est attendu par les
magistrats il appartiendra au poids
réglementaire d'en fixer des critères
d'appréciation et non l inverse
enfin nous pouvons nous féliciter de la
simplification de la procédure et de la
rationalisation de la gamme des
sanctions applicables aux mineurs la
principale innovation de cette réforme
procédurales consiste à ancrer la césure
de la procédure
comme principe et l'audience unique
comme exception le mineur sera jugé
selon la procédure de mise à l'épreuve
et éducative
elle se déroulera en trois phases une
audience de culpabilité une période de
mise à l'épreuve éducative et une
audience de sanctions encadré dans délai
court 10 jours a trois mois pour les
audiences de culpabilité sims à 9 mois
pour l'audience de sanctions cette
procédure a le mérite de fixer
rapidement le mineur sur son sort est de
permettre à la victime d'être indemnisé
dans les meilleurs délais néanmoins son
efficacité dépendra non seulement des
moyens dont disposera la justice des
mineurs pour respecter les délais non
contraignant mais la capacité qu'auront
les services de la pjj protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse à mettre en
oeuvre de manière instantanée les
mesures éducatives
à cette fin la commission de loi adopté
un amendement obligeant la pjj a fixé la
date de mise en oeuvre des mesures
éducatives provisoire à l'audience de
culpabilité la continuité et la
cohérence éducative sont au coeur de la
réforme pour les mineurs déjà fortement
connu et pour lesquels il existe un
risque de non représentation ils peuvent
être jugés au cours d'une audience
unique qui doit rester l'exception
la rationalisation de la gamme des
sanctions constituent un enjeu
d'efficacité dans la politique de lutte
contre la délinquance des mineurs afin
que d'une part la mine la mesure soit
mieux adapté à la situation du mineur et
d'autre part mieux comprise par le jeune
donc vous comprenez les chers collègues
cette modernisation du code de la
justice pénale des mineurs est une bonne
réforme voulue est attendue
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous ne
comprenons pas monsieur le ministre la
méthode employée peu respectueuse et
travail parlementaire et à marche forcée
nous appesantir ont pas sur le recours
aux ordonnances le parole des l'isthme
des formes ne s'imposait pas le contexte
45 n'est pas celui de 2019 un sujet
d'ampleur tels que le nouveau code de
justice pénale des mineurs auraient
justifié un vrai débat parlementaire est
pas au détour d'une loi de ratification
nous nous appesantir ont pas sur le
calendrier parlementaire contre 1
la crise la cause vide a naturellement
bousculer les priorités législatives
alors que l'assemblée nationale a adopté
cette ordonnance de près de 250 articles
entre deux votes budgétaire le sénat est
saisie en trois jours alors qu'il y
attendent ordonnance qui attendent leur
ratification
alors monsieur ministre pourquoi tant de
précipitation
pourquoi vouloir faire adopter à marche
marche forcée cette réforme d'ampleur
attendu au point ne pas respecter le
travail est parlementaire en rédigeant
la partie réglementaire avant les débats
au sénat en donnant des instructions
juridiction sur l'application de la
réforme juste après l'adoption de la
petite loi par l'assemblée nationale
après dix ans de gestation la réforme de
la justice pénale des mineurs n'est plus
à quelques mois près la commission des
lois du sénat à l'unanimité a considéré
que le report de l'entrée en vigueur de
la réforme au 30 septembre 2020 était
sage non pas comme nous pouvons
l'entendre pour enterrer la réforme mais
bien au contraire
parce que nous croyons au bien fondé de
ce nouveau code pénal de la justice des
mineurs pour lui donner toutes les
chances d'atteindre son objectif de
réduction de la délinquance
car monsieur le ministre même avec tous
les efforts d'anticipation les
juridictions pour les mineurs ne sont
pas prêtes
la crise l'a coville la grève des
avocats n'ont pas permis d'écouler tous
les stocks possible certes des moyens
humains ont été affectées mais en nombre
insuffisant pour réduire les délais pour
réduire les stocks dans des délais aussi
contraint et permettent un double
audiencement maîtriser car si les
magistrats spécialisés ont absorbé les
enjeux de la réforme c'est loin d'être
le cas des greffiers toujours en nombre
insuffisant et des éducateurs de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
dont le rôle dans la réussite de la
réforme est cruciale
la baisse du budget de formation de
lattes et jj pour 2021 est un facteur
d'inquiétude suffit supplémentaires mais
surtout les outils informatiques à la
disposition des magistrats de la pjj ne
seront pas prêts dans deux mois le
logiciel cassiopée qui permet le suivi
des tribunaux judiciaires ne sera pas
opérationnel faut dire que les
informaticiens du mystère ont d'autres
priorités puisque cassiopée n'a toujours
pas intégré la réforme du bloc bm de
même le ciel parcours de la pjj est
essentielle pour la continuité
éducative coeur de la réforme ne sera
totalement déployé qu'en 2000 décembre
2021 alors monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
beaucoup vont trop vite et nulle part la
direction est plus importante que la
vitesse ce sage proverbe doit nous
guider pour faire en sorte que la
réforme du code de la justice pénale des
mineurs qui est sur la bonne direction
aille au bout de ses objectifs
c'est pourquoi nous proposons de
ratifier cette année cette ordonnance
est d'en reporter avec sagesse l'entrée
en vigueur au 30 septembre 2021 même
façon à la discussion de la motion
tendance à opposer la question préalable
mesdames eliane assassi cécile cukierman
année les membres du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes ont
déposé une motion distribuée sous le
numéro 1 rectifié tendant à opposer la
question préalable au texte en
discussion
la parole est à même la présidente
assassi pour la motion et pour dix
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues
ce projet de loi de ratification nous
interroge tant sur la forme que sur le
fond
si l'examen d'un tel texte a été
perturbé cela n'est pas en raison du
contexte sanitaire mais bien en raison
de la méthode choisie par le
gouvernement pour réformer une fois de
prendre une fois encore par mois dans 2
gousses la précipitation dans laquelle
cette réforme a été présenté un
amendement au détour d'une séance
publique pour habiliter le gouvernement
à légiférer par voie d'ordonnancé puis
discuté deux jours à l'assemblée
nationale et quelques demi-journées à
venir au sénat en procédure accélérée
illustre un certain irrespect pour les
travaux du parlement dont notre chambre
haute
comme en témoigne la diffusion de votre
circulaire le 18 décembre dernier ou
encore la publication de la partie
réglementaire de ce code avant l'examen
complet de la partie législative
monsieur le ministre vous avez fait
valoir que cette réforme était le fruit
de plus de dix ans de consultations
quatre gardes des sceaux et presque
autant de majorité lors est préparé
pourquoi donc en bout de course ne
laissait au parlement qu'un article de
ratification et quatre jours de débats
pour passer en revue les 270 cet article
contient ce nouveau code justice paix de
justice pénale des mineurs sans l'étude
d'impact que permet un projet de loi
ordinaire puisqu'il s'agit d'un projet
de loi de ratification sans base de
comparaison clair et solide des deux
ordonnances finalement si ce n'est le
rapport rapide de notre commission et le
rapport plus que rapide de la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale
avec cette approche le gouvernement mais
le parlement dans une nasse faisant
usage point par point de tous les
mécanismes permettant de faire passer au
plus vite un maximum de mesures
finalement ce que ce texte prône sur le
fond à savoir traiter le maximum
d'affaires
le plus rapidement possible et en
sollicitant le moins de professionnels
possible collégialité mise à mal dans
certains cas processus déjà engagés pour
la justice dans son ensemble avec la
réforme des doublés dans le cas de la
justice rendu aux demandeurs ce que ce
texte prône donc sur le fond se retrouve
dans la manière de faire
quand on doit les choses autrement
lorsque l'unique arctique du projet de
loi initial ne comportait qu'un seul
l'arc il demandant le blanc-seing du
parlement pour la rédaction de
l'ensemble à nouveau code pénal des
mineurs issus d'un héritage historique
qui n'est pas des moindres
l' ordonnance de 45 et avec elle toute
la préhension nouvelles de la justice
qui devait être rendu aux mineurs dans
un contexte de reconstruction du pays on
aurait pu s'imaginer que le contexte
inédit dans lequel s'inscrit ce débat il
fait réfléchir le gouvernement autrement
en considérant la jeunesse comme en 45
comme un atout fort pour surmonter la
crise sanitaire et économique que nous
traversons est donc méritant une
attention plus particulière et attentif
que celle proposée aujourd'hui mais une
ellipse temporelle semble être passée
par là l'héritage historique de 45 a été
troquée pas sur la forme bien sûr il est
rappelé et encensé à plusieurs reprises
mais sur le fond contre celui des
tristes années 2000 en matière de
réformes pour la justice des mineurs
dans sa célèbre décision du 29 août 2002
relative à la loi d'orientation et de
programmation pour la justice du 9
septembre 2002 dite loi perben 1
le conseil constitutionnel a érigé le
principe de spécificités de la justice
pénale des mineurs au rang de principe
fondamental reconnu par les lois de la
république face à l'inde est là à la
délinquance des mineurs
le choix de faire primer la réponse
éducative sur la réponse répressive
apparaît donc nettement établie par le
juge constitutionnel
mais comme l'expliquent l'enseignante
chercheuse en droit public à l'école
nationale de protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse nada nadia bedia soucieux de
lutter contre l'insécurité que
générerait la délinquance juvénile
problématique qui a trouvé une place
solide dans les débats publics
le législateur français a cédé à
l'instar de nombreux pays aux réflexes
sécuritaires ainsi l'arsenal pénal tend
à se diversifier à se durcir depuis la
loi perben ii 2002 pour apporter des
réponses à un phénomène de délinquance
juvénile
jugez en forte croissance les précisions
apportées par les réformes successives
du droit pénal sont traduites par le
développement d'un mouvement visant une
forte responsabilisation des mineurs
cette dynamique a produit la mise en
place d'un dispositif pénal de plus en
plus coercitif et l'idée d'un droit
pénal des mineurs de plus en plus proche
du droit général ainsi que le recours à
un schéma répressives destinées à
permettre la rééducation des mineurs
délinquants exception de minorités pour
les plus de saisons droits de la défense
pas toujours garanti par exemple la loi
perben 1
en parallèle au contrôle judiciaire pour
les mineurs et au sursis mise à
l'épreuve à créer des centres éducatifs
fermés la loi sarkozy en 2003 a quant à
elle créé de nouveaux types
d'infractions venant stigmatiser
davantage une jeunesse des quartiers
comme l' entrave à la circulation dans
les halls d'immeuble ou la participation
à un groupement en vue de commettre un
délit ou encore le fichage les mineurs
auteurs d'infractions pénales pour ne
citer que ces lois
dans leur sillage le gouvernement crée
aujourd'hui 20 nouveaux centres
éducatifs fermés
il brouille le temps éducatif et le
temps judiciaire en les insérant dans
des délais at laz intenable avec la
procédure de césure et avait la
possibilité de balayer les jugements en
une audience unique ainsi que celle d'un
jugement sur sanction sans collégialité
ce bref retour en arrière est important
pour comprendre selon nous la lente mais
sûre entreprise de démolition des grands
principes de l'ordonnancé de 45 qui ne
soyons pas naïfs
si elle était révolutionnaire en son
temps n'était pas magique non plus
faisant passer les établissements
publics qualifié avant guerre de bagnes
d'enfants à l'éducation surveillée
il s'agissait finalement avant tout
d'une prise de conscience collective de
l'importance d'éduquer les
deux points de prendre soin de l'enfance
carlu mineurs cela a été dit est souvent
un être en souffrance mais surtout
surtout le mineur n'est pas un adulte
c'est un enfant un jeune en construction
en devenir
c'est pourquoi traiter de la justice des
mineurs n'est pas une simple question
juridique cette matière sensible qui est
la rééducation de la jeunesse en
difficulté amène à une réflexion au sein
de laquelle s'entremêlent et se
confondent le philosophique le juridique
le judiciaire et l'éducatif et je dirais
même l'historique et le sociologique
car les mineurs enfants et adolescents
sont aussi le reflet du monde qui les
entoure leur environnement social et
familial bien sûr mais aussi la société
dans son ensemble marqué également ces
vingt dernières années par l'avènement
d'internet et du monde numérique avec
lequel la jeunesse a évolué certes
l'ensemble des professionnels de la
justice magistrats procureurs ont
insisté un glissement vers une
aggravation des actes commis par des
mineurs primo-délinquants mais cela
n'est pas sans cause
comme l'expliqué martin levrel
commissaire divisionnaire à roubaix lors
d'un colloque à l'assemblée nationale
sur les 70 ans de l'ordonance de 45 avec
l'explosion d'internet
nous sommes pour ainsi dire passé des
dégradations de voitures pour y dérober
des autoradios à des jeunes dans
certains quartiers difficiles qui disent
vouloir former des bandes comme au
mexique ou en amérique latine
s'autoalimente ans autour de leurs
fantasmes de criminalité organisée
organisés que des médias de masse et
internet véhicule volontiers tout cela
est à prendre en compte
et cette réforme n'est pas né de rien
non plus elle s'ancre dans cette dérive
répressive qui se contentent de soigner
des maux profonds en s'attaquant
uniquement aux symptômes
cette réforme entérine un profond un
profond changement de paradigme le
principe de la primauté de l'éducatif
sur le répressif est largement atténué
si ce n'est un verset avec ce texte sous
couvert d'une délinquance juvénile qui
aurait muté et serait devenu davantage
violent tous ont su plantes l'éducatif
sur le répressif c'est un cercle vicieux
ainsi des enfants d'apache guy des
enfants d'ouvriers sous la monarchie de
juillet aux enfants des quartiers
populaires à nettoyer au kärcher dans
les années sarkozy
on en arrive aujourd'hui sous des termes
plus feutrés certes mais aussi plus
hypocrite avisé les mineurs non
accompagnés
les fameux mn à autrement dit les
mineurs isolés étrangers que certains
souhaiteraient voir expulser de notre
pays à la moindre preuve petites
infractions mesure je cite la
rapporteure en commission
malheureusement inconstitutionnelle
laissez moi vous dire où vous rappeler
que le fait que ces mineurs soient venus
d'ailleurs n'en fait pas moins des
enfants comme les nôtres et que vous
leur devons en plus de la protection et
de l'asile là même la même application
de notre justice
que cela plaise ou que cela ne plaise
pas les chers collègues la philosophie
avec laquelle ce texte est abordée
reflète vous l'aurez compris et nous en
semble convaincu pour notre part toute
une vision de la société
c'est l'adopter de concerts pas la
majorité gouvernementale à l'assemblée
nationale et la majorité sénatoriale de
droite ici au sénat qui ne vise pas
uniquement à simplifier sur la forme
l'ordonance de 45 mais bien à la réforme
et au fond pour la marquer du sceau des
dispositifs répressifs qu'ils ont terni
ces dernières années au sein du modèle
socio économique libérale bien établie
dans lequel évolue notre pays
l' approche répressive des dérives
quelle qu'elle soit et dès le plus jeune
âge a hélas de nombreux triste jour
devant être pourtant il est peu de
problèmes aussi graves que ce qui
concerne la protection de l'enfance et
parmi eux
ceux qui ont trait au sort de l'enfance
traduites en justice
la france n'est pas assez riche
d'enfants pour qu'elle ait le droit de
négliger tout ce qui peut en faire des
êtres st ses premières phrases de
l'ordonance de 45 héritage du conseil
national de la résistance continueront
pour nous à être une boussole dans tous
nos débats
merci la parole est à monsieur thani
mohamed soilihi contre la motion et pour
dix minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux mais chers collègues je
vous rassure tout de suite je ne vais
pas utiliser les dix minutes jeunes
allongerait pas à l'excellent aux débats
qui débutent à peine toutefois justement
parce que la motion qui nous est
présenté vise à les interrompre sans
délai je tenais à expliquer les raisons
pour que nous conduirons a voté contre
la motion se sont exposés des motifs
souligne que le projet de loi qui écrit
un autre heure du jour ne serait
acceptable ni sur le fond ni sur la
forme bien permettez moi de vous dire
chers collègues que la présente motion
nous semble présenter elle-même cette
double carence de fond et de forme pour
ne pas anticiper les éléments qui
interviendront dans la discussion
générale
je m'en tiendrai ici à la forme il nous
apparaît tout à fait singulier et
contradictoire des cartes et d'un revers
de la main
un débat que nous avons sollicité à
plusieurs reprises et à juste titre
auprès de vous monsieur le garde des
sceaux et de votre prédécesseur
un débat qui intervient donc
effectivement ce soir conformément aux
engagements pris et dans le cadre duquel
nous est soumis l'ensemble des articles
du code de la justice pénale des mineurs
il nous semble indispensable que le
débat sur cette codification attendu par
les acteurs du terrain puissent se tenir
et nous voteront donc contre cette
motion
quel est l'avis de la commission mer à
porter merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le sénat a suffisamment relevé la
problématique de la méthode et de
l'absence de débat donc pour se priver
ce soir d'un débat autour de ce texte
fondamental de la justice pénale des
mineurs dont nous considérons que c'est
un texte qui répond à des objectifs
notamment de justice de la délinquance
des mineurs et qui met en place une
réforme de modernisant cette justice
pénale dans un objectif de mieux
répondre aux besoins et aux objectifs de
la délinquance aujourd'hui de notre pays
dans l'actualité nous rappelle
régulièrement les enjeux donc pour ces
raisons nous sont bien évidemment
défavorable à cette question préalable
merci quel est l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur le garde des sceaux madame la
présidente monsieur le président la
commission des lois mais reporter sans
surprise le gouvernement est défavorable
vous l'imaginez bien quelques mots
madame la sénatrice très très rapidement
très rapidement peut-être pour corriger
d'avoir quelques inexactitudes
le budget de la formation de la dpjj n'a
pas diminué contrairement à ce que vous
dites vous l'avez affirmé performances
et une petite erreur et nous aurons sans
doute l'occasion d'y revenir ensuite
ensuite
ensuite s'agissant des nanars ou dit ne
vous en déplaise les maynats le mc
mineurs et
ce sont des mineurs comme les autres qui
ne sont pas qui ne sont brèves ou
répondre je compte y le mans gentiment
et ce sont des mineurs qui seront pris
en charge
évidemment par ce texte quand il entrera
en vigueur
je conteste mais avec la plus farouche
détermination l'idée qu' on n'est pas
discuter sur ce texte je vous rappeler
quand même que toi ça démarre en 2008
c'est la commission varinard 32
parlementaires des spécialistes du droit
des mineurs 2009 rédaction d'un avant
projet de loi portant code de justice
pénale des mineurs
soumis à de très nombreuses
consultations
ce sont des questionnaires qui ont été
adressées à tous les intervenants de la
justice des mineurs
c'est en 2010 une proposition de réforme
porté par l'association française des
magistrats de la jeunesse etc etc etc je
veux pas faire la liste
j'ai promis et je vous ai promis que je
serais bref et je tiendrai donc main
parole sur ce point mais dire qu'il n'ya
pas eu de concertation ce n est pas vrai
et puis le travail de l'assemblée
nationale et le travail de la commission
des lois et du c'est que ce travail a
été riche constructif
j'ai dit les convergences que nous
avions et j'ai dit aussi les divergences
ce qui subsistait alors dire par
ailleurs mais ça c'est pour moi de la
posture je le dis sans aucune acrimonie
que ce texte à vocation de détruire leur
donnons de 45
bah c'est très curieux c'est pas vrai
non pas du tout avoué dire si si je vais
redire mon nom on va pas évoluer
beaucoup
non ça n'est pas vrai madame la
sénatrice c'est tout le contraire c'est
la primauté de l'éducatif
je vais vous donner deux raisons mois de
d'aimer ce texte et ce texte n'est pas
le mien où le savez un thé loin de dire
des choses que ça commence en 2008 se le
rappeler tout à l'heure il ya eu 4 garde
des sceaux n'est quand même
aucun délai dans la procédure actuelle
viens t'en sers et la mise en examen ces
générateurs le stock ça parce que quand
vous avez un gamin qui est en liberté
quand y'a aucun délai les dossiers
s'empilent
ça c'est une certitude et une réalité
pardon de le dire je vous donne un
deuxième nom je vous donne un deuxième
élément qui devrait emporter votre
conviction peut-être est-elle
définitivement fait mais on a des gammes
ans aujourd'hui qui commettent des faits
ils ont 16 ans ils sont jugés ils en ont
22 est ce que c'est un sens damman
d'abord posons nous la question est-ce
que ça a un sens pour eux parce qu'avant
d'être sénateur garde des sceaux députée
magistrat on est peut-être père de
famille pères ou mères de famille
écoutez si je fais dans l'éducatif ou
dont le punitifs à l'égard des enfants
ils sont grands maintenant mauvais ça
intervient pas six mois après c'est tout
de suite
pardonnez-moi mais enfin quand un gamin
saison commettent une infraction et
qu'il est jugé quand il en a 22 qu'il
est marié qui là qu'il a changé de vie
mais ça la salle mais je jouerai de près
terminée
ça n'a strictement aucun sens la justice
la justice
elle ne tourne pas à vie pour elle même
elle a un sens pédagogique surtout pour
les gamins la sanction doit d'intervenir
tout de suite j'ai rappelé les délais
ici on a d'abord une décision sur la
culpabilité et ensuite une mise à
l'épreuve une première mise à l'épreuve
et puis un jugement sur le quantum et
l'éducatif peut se prolonger au delà de
cette décision mais c'est formidable ça
chef s'alimente désolé ça ne naît pas
système actuel où on a des idées des
procédures qui connaissent leur épilogue
18 mois de moyenne c'est vous dire
pas pour les pour les plus longues
procédures c'est bien au delà de 18 mois
ça n'a aucun sens c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs
à l'exception de quelques-uns en
première lecture il ya une forme
d'unanimité de consensus sur ce texte
bien jeu
j'espère vous avoir convaincu j'en suis
pas certain de la sénatrice et comme je
n'ai pas le goût de l'effort inutile je
vais tout de suite ma soir merci il ya
toutes les explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je vis donc consulté le
sénat sur la motion tendance à opposer
la question préalable
je rappelle que l'adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
alors qui est pour cette motion qui est
contre qui s'abstient
la motion n'est pas adopté madame la
présidente monsieur garde des sceaux
madame la rapporteure messieurs
président de la commission permettez moi
monsieur ministre de commencer par ces
quelques mots de votre illustre
prédécesseur robert badinter un mineur
c'est un être en devenir
l'objectif premier de la justice des
mineurs c'est de les intégrer ou de les
réinsérer dans la société
alors oui au nom de ce noble objectif
l'ordonnancé de 1945 se devait d'être
remise à plat réécrite enrichi et enfin
codifié en effet une quarantaine de
réformes depuis 1945
comme l'a précisé tout à l'heure madame
la rapporteure ou rendu ce texte
fondateur bien complexe difficile à
appréhender
y compris pour les professionnels et
parfois en incohérence avec le code
pénal sur un aspect purement formel ce
projet de loi est donc tout à fait
bienvenu cette ordonnance de 1945 nous
donne en héritage un socle de principes
da primauté de l'éducatif sur le
répressif
la spécialisation des juridictions pour
mineurs et l'atténuation de leurs
responsabilités pénales des principes
fondamentaux qu'il était indispensable
de ne pas perdre 2
car juger les mineurs c'est avant tout
trouver un équilibre délicat entre la
nécessaire protection de la société et
l'indispensable prise en compte de
l'intérêt de l'enfant
ce citoyen en devenir un enfant est un
ensemble et on ne peut pas lui prêter la
même compréhension du monde qui
l'entourent et de ses actes qu'un adulte
ainsi en cette matière est peut-être
plus que dans d'autres
gardons nous des raisonnements
simplistes et des jugements hâtifs et
silence on n'a pas la même compréhension
du monde
il n'a pas non plus la même temporalité
cam adultes
lorsqu'on à 50 en un an c'est un
cinquantième de sa vie lorsqu on a 10
ans et 1 10e
soit beaucoup plus et six mois 12 mois 2
ans pour un adulte peuvent équivaloir à
3 ans 5 ans 10 ans pour un enfant bref
c'est long c'est pourquoi raccourcir les
délais et créer une césure avec une
première audience sur la culpabilité
dans les trois mois qui suivent le début
de la procédure devrait apporter une
véritable amélioration pour l'enfant
jugées mais aussi pour la victime qui
pourra ainsi voir sa demande prise en
compte rapidement ce temps judiciaire
long c'est aussi un grand nombre de
mineurs en détention provisoire fin 2020
80% des mineurs détenus étaient en
détention provisoire pour les majeures
celle de l'ordre d'un tiers ce qui
pourrait laisser entendre que beaucoup
de ces mineurs n'auraient pas dû passer
par la case prison
lackey de case n'est pas on le sait le
meilleur lieu d'éducation et de
réinsertion après cette première
audience si le mineur est déclaré
coupable vienne six à neuf mois de suivi
éducatif devant lui permettre d'intégrer
sa culpabilité et de comprendre la
portée de ses actes et surtout de
prendre des mesures évitant toute
réalité
toute réitération c'est alors qu
interviendra une seconde audience qui
décidera de la sanction
en tenant compte du comportement et de
l'implication de la dickens de
l'adolescent durant son parcours
éducatif
cette volonté d'aller plus vite nous ne
pouvons que la saluer monsieur le
ministre
j'attire cependant votre attention sur
l'importance de donner à notre justice
les moyens de vos ambitions je dirais
même de nos ambitions
en l'état actuel des choses il est à
craindre que ces délais ne puisse être
respecté
tout comme ils ont du mal à être tenue
aujourd'hui
permettez moi de prendre ici un exemple
très concret depuis la loi du 27 mars
2012 de programmation et d'exécution des
peines et en particulier son article 12
alinéa 3
les services de la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse sont tenues de prendre en
charge le mineur ayant fait l'objet
d'une décision judiciaire au plus tard
cinq jours après cette décision
l'intention est louable et en pratique
les services convoque bien les mineurs
dans ce délai afin d'être en conformité
avec la loi
mais c'est souvent simplement pour lui
succès un rendez vous ultérieur souvent
un mois après ceux de moyens la réalité
des cinq jours ses 35 jours
là encore un problème de temporalité
mais qui n'est pas liée à l'âge des
protagonistes plus sûrement à mon avis à
leur nombre que ce soit côté mineurs ou
côté pjj lors d'une audition notre
collègue maryse carrère vous interroger
sur les moyens de la pjj et le besoin de
renforcement par rapport à la réforme
vous lui avez assez justement répondu
qu'il n'y aurait pas plus de mineurs et
que le travail de la pjj ne serait pas
très différent c'est juste mais les
difficultés de lattes et jj resteront
également les mêmes et leur capacité à
accompagner les mineurs et à les prendre
en charge dans un temps court
chose qu'ils ont du mal à faire
aujourd'hui lors sera tout aussi
compliqué si vous ne les aidez pas alors
monsieur le ministre au regard de
l'ambition de ce test ne partons pas du
principe qu'une fois de plus la tendance
suivra et donnant à notre justice les
moyens humains et matériels et je pense
ici vous vous en doutez bien à
l'informatique pour s'assurer du succès
de cette réforme
je ne reviendrai pas sur la présomption
simple donnons décernement pour les
mineurs de moins de 13 ans voilà qui
nous met en conformité avec le droit
international
je sais du tout de même à ce sujet le
travail de notre rapporteur comme vous
l'avez fait vous même d'ailleurs
monsieur milices qui apporte quelques
pistes permettant de définir le
discernement afin d'éviter que selon la
juridiction de laquelle dépend le mineur
voix du juge auquel il est affecté
la disparité du concept soit trop forte
je voudrais par contre revenir sur le
juge des libertés et de la détention
paris n'est pas la france la france est
maillé est pourvu que ça dure
de petits tribunaux ne disposant pas de
pléthore de vue la libération et des
détentions alors vous décrire on n'a pas
non plus beaucoup de jus des enfants
mais je pense qu'on a un peu plus de jus
d'enfants des enfants que de juge des
libertés et de la détention et donc du
coup spécialisé 1 j l
justice des mineurs risquent de nous
consisté qu'à estampillé chaque jld de
cette qualification au prix peut-être
d'une heure ou deux de formation sans
véritablement créer une spécialisation
les juges des enfants nous avons
rencontré comprenant parfaitement qu'il
fallait dissocier les deux fonctions ont
plutôt proposé que ce soit un autre juge
des enfants qui statue de la liberté et
de la détention
nous aurions alors bien une dissociation
doublée d'une vraie spécialisation
enfin je ne peux également que souscrire
à la proposition de la commission de
repousser l'entrée en application de ce
texte à septembre 2021
mais j'ai bien entendu le côté
rendez-nous le jld et peut-être qu'on
vous donnera du temps mais tous les
intervenants effectivement s'accordent
pour demander quelques mois y compris
ceux qui sont favorables et attendre
cette réforme
alors monsieur le ministre vous qui nous
dit régulièrement de faire confiance aux
juges
à votre tour faites leur confiance en
leur donnant pleinement de temps de se
préparer à cette réforme qui le méritent
en définitive vous l'aurez compris du
groupe union centriste
votre à ce texte mais restera vigilant
sur son application concrète
la parole est à madame laurence harribey
du groupe socialistes écologistes et
républicains pour un neuf minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission madame la rapporteure lors de
votre audition monsieur le ministre vous
déclariez je ne connais pas de réforme
qui ne suscite pas de large opposition
pour qui aime les joutes oratoires
nous pourrions vous répondre par ce
proverbe chinois
logique puisque qu'ils réforment souvent
des formes plutôt que de balayer d'un
revers de main les oppositions nous nous
sommes attachés à déterminer qui dit
quoi pourquoi comment à quel moment
au nom de quelle réalité ou quels
principes
ceci pour répondre à une question simple
pourquoi une réforme en tentant d'y
trouver le sens et la légitimité car
prendre une réforme comme seule réponse
à un problème posé c'est se réformer de
toute autre action possible
qu'est ce que nous retenons de ce
travail
oui une certaine unanimité pour une
réforme la nécessité d'une réforme
et pourtant des blocages importants pour
notre part nous souscrivons en effet aux
principes de la réforme pour permettre
une meilleure lisibilité
d'autres l'ont dit d'un corpus
législatif amende et près de 40 fois
depuis 45 avec des modifications qui au
fil des années a fait perdre de la
cohérence au texte d'origine et a manqué
de clarification nous sommes favorable
aussi à une réaffirmation des trois
principes de l'ordonance 45 et vous
l'avez rappelé ils y sont bien tripotée
de l'éducatif sur le répressif ce qui ne
veut pas dire pour autant qu'il n'y ait
pas de sanction spécialisation de la
justice des mineurs et atténuation de la
responsabilité en fonction de l'âge de
même nous souscrivons aux 3 attendu de
la réforme l'instauration d'une
présomption dié
irresponsabilité avant 13 ans qui nous
permet de nous mettre encore ferme en
conformité avec les conventions
internationales
l'accélération du jugement via une
procédure en deux temps culpabilité puis
audience de sanctions avec une mise à
l'épreuve
entre les deux est la volonté de
remettre la victime au centre mais
au-delà de ces attendus louable une
analyse plus fine montre que la réforme
actes
en fait la remise en cause progressive
de la philosophie de l'ordonance de 45
en effet peu à peu du fait des mutations
sociales et de la perception du jeune
dans la société
l'impératif de la prise en compte de la
personnalité des auteurs d'infractions
et de leur contexte de vie a été
abandonnée en particulier pour les
mineurs les plus âgés et ceci au profit
de la notion plutôt de trouble de
l'ordre public qui lui doit être
rétribués par une sanction pénale avec
un abandon progressif de la référence à
l'enfant et à son intérêt la question
qui était à l'origine pourquoi punir
devient comment punir la perception est
importante sur ce plan une et vers une
évolution qui a été particulièrement
marquée dans les années 2000 puisque
entre 2001 et 2008 pas moins de huit
textes dont 7 de nature législative se
sont traduites par trois tendances
lourdes qu'on retrouve finalement dans
votre texte
un renforcement du volet répression un
alignement progressif sur les textes
concernant les adultes un renforcement
du pouvoir du parquet de la police en
liaison directe avec les autorités
politiques locales et cette évolution
est interrogé par les chiffres puisque
93 % des affaires connaissent une
réponse pénale
s'agissant des mineurs contre 88%
concernant
les majeures par contre 82% des mineurs
incarcérés ne sont pas jugés et relève
de la détention provisoire d'où
finalement cette interrogation sur le
renforcement du volet pénal ne
fallait-il pas plutôt se poser la
question des moyens consacrés à la
justice des mineurs et éviter ces fameux
82%
cette analyse nous conduit à mettre
l'accent sur trois divergences de fond
qui fonde nos amendements les 3dvia
divergences d'abord une divergence sur
la méthode qui revient à une divergence
de fond je reviendrai pas là dessus
puisque les collègues ont insisté notre
rapporteur vous l'a rappelé avoir
procéder par ordonnance pour un texte
aussi important est largement
contestable
si on peut comprendre le recours à
l'ordonnancé dans le contexte de 1945
l'enjeu de ce code pouvait mériter mieux
et avoir une réflexion beaucoup plus
large
une deuxième divergences de fond pour
nous c'est que ce texte privilégie
contrairement à ce que vous dites la
répression au détriment du temps
éducatif du fait de 3 insuffisances il
ne privilégie pas dans les attendus mais
dans la réalité de ce qui va se passer
la question des délais cercle objective
et de raccourcir mêler les délais
inscrit dans le texte sont des délais
indicatif qui ne sont pas encadrés ils
faut-il rappeler que dans l'article de
45 dans l'article 12 13
il y avait une obligation que les
mesures éducatives soient mises en
oeuvre dans les cinq jours
donc si le dr pas respecté c'est qu'il
ya des problèmes ailleurs deuxième
insuffisances la place trollage laisser
aux procédures d'exception qui ne
respectent pas la phase éducative et qui
conduira imanquablement un durcissement
des mesures prononcées et de fait un
rapprochement de la justice des mineurs
avec celle des majeurs
enfin troisième insuffisances la
question des moyens qui est une vraie
question de fond car elle détermine la
crédibilité même de la réforme
la troisième divergence plein
je mens souligné par madame le
rapporteur concerne la faisabilité
matérielle en amont et en aval d'une
crise sanitaire qui est venu aggraver
les difficultés de la justice des
mineurs
sur ce point la quasi totalité des
acteurs souligne les difficultés et
quand la quasi totalité des acteurs
swing une difficulté c'est que quelque
part il ya quand même un problème et
dire que tout sera prêt relève pour nous
un peu de la méthode coué
ces divergences fondent nos propositions
d'amendements qui repose sur trois
points de vigilance
d'abord le report de l'entrée en vigueur
du code pénal de la justice des ménages
on ne reviendrait pas là-dessus puisque
le rapporteur a fait des propositions
deuxième point de vigilance la question
de la responsabilité atténuée en
fonction de l'âge delage et notamment le
caractère irréfragable de
l'irresponsabilité pénale des mineurs de
moins de 13 ans nous considérons que
seule une présomption irréfragable
auraient permis de répondre aux
engagements internationaux de la france
est d'assurer aux mineurs en conflit
avec la loi une égalité de traitement
cette question est liée à celle de la
définition du discernement qui ne nous
semble pas satisfaisant dans le texte et
là monsieur le ministre nous vous
rejoignons puisque nous avons présenté
un amendement qui va dans le sens du
vôtre enfin la question de l'audience
unique pour les réitérant pour nous
reste problématique car elle tend à se
confondre avec une comparer une
comparution immédiate ce qui porte
atteinte à la fois au principe de
spécialisation des juridictions et à
celui de la primauté de l'éducatif donc
les divergences ne sont pas sur les
attendus
elles sont bien sûr la situation
actuellement de la justice des mineurs
et de ce qui risque de se passer
en conclusion on peut regretter que
cette réforme ne soit essentiellement
que procédurale est concentré sur le
volet pénal
avec cette réforme on peut se demander
en quoi on s'attaque plus qui hier aux
carences éducatives que l'on prétend
combattre une piste n'a malheureusement
pas été suivie celle
de la déjudiciarisation de nombre de
procédures au profit d'un système civil
construit pour distraire du judiciaire
les infractions se rapprochant des
incivilités et le couple et le rôle des
autorités politiques locales qui joue un
rôle particulier dans la réinsertion et
dans la prise en compte de la déconne
délinquance des mineurs un code de
l'enfance incluant les dispositions
civiles et pénales auraient ainsi permis
de mieux prendre en compte la volonté si
toutefois cette volonté existe toujours
de considérer le mineur en conflit avec
la loi comme un enfant à protéger vous
l'aurez compris notre position est pour
l'instant relativement distante de ce
texte là mais nous avons présenté des
amendements et nous espérons que le
texte pourra évoluer
je vous remercie merci la parole est un
monsieur pierre médevielle pour un 5
minutes pour le groupe des indépendants
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
l'ordonnancé de 1945 sur la justice
pénale applicable aux mineurs a fait
l'objet de près de 40 modifications au
cours son histoire au fondement du droit
pénal spécifique aux mineurs se trouvent
l'idée centrale de discernement essai de
l'importance de travailler à remettre le
mineur dans le droit chemin
malgré des nombreuses modifications que
j'ai évoqué un principe a toujours guidé
la réponse pénale que notre pays
appliquent aux mineurs délinquants
il s'agit de favoriser les mesures
éducatives
lorsqu'il est possible d'éviter le
recours à des mesures répressives
il me semble que nous retrouvons tous au
poste de philosophie centrée sur la
nécessité d'assurer l'insertion ou la
réception de ces jeunes
la réforme que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est nécessaire
nous allons néanmoins souhaité qu'elle
soit menée dans un contexte plus apaisé
le recours à une ordonnance qui
plusieurs courses il a accéléré
contraire légèrement le débat
parlementaire
cette réforme doit néanmoins se faire
notamment pour permettre à la france de
respecter ses engagements internationaux
mais aussi pour rendre cette justice
plus efficace et plus juste
notre groupe soutient l'extension de la
spécialisation des juridictions pour les
mineurs ne sont pas des justiciable
comme les autres
il importe donc que les magistrats en
charge et une connaissance fine et
spécifiques de ces affaires la
commission des lois encore accru sa
spécialisation en renforçant la
compétence du juge des enfants
cette spécialisation ne dispensent pas
du respect des conditions du procès
équitable
nous nous réjouissons que la phase de
mise en examen sont supprimés et que la
procédure satisfasse maintenant
pleinement aux principes d'impartialité
c'était indispensable
nous félicitons aussi du fait que les
mineurs entendus dans le cadre
d'auditions livres seront désormais
accompagnés d'un avocat comme c'est le
cas pour les majeurs et mineurs doivent
bénéficier d'une protection renforcée
nous soutenons donc également
l'interdiction du principe du recours à
la vidéo conférence pour l'audience
concernant leur détention provisoire en
plus d'une justice équitable
les mineurs ont besoin d'une justice
rapide c'est un point crucial pour
l'ensemble des justiciables français
mais est encore plus pour nos jeunes
nous saluons l'objectif poursuivi en
matière de réduction des délais de
justice pénale des mineurs
il est important que le jugement de
mineur puisse intervenir rapidement et
si possible évidemment avant sa majorité
ou l'avait largement souligné monsieur
le garde des sceaux dans notre
intervention en préambule au delà de
l'amélioration de la célérité de la
procédure
nous saluons aussi sa simplification la
décomposition en quatre modules de la
mesure éducative judiciaire provisoire
apporte une utile clarté il permet de
prononcer la mesure la plus adaptée
possible à la personnalité du mineur
cette réforme nécessaire je le répète
est attendue néanmoins se pose la
question de son entrée en vigueur
en suivant l'excellente travailler notre
reporter agnès canayer
la commission des lois a reporté la date
son application du 31 mars au 30
septembre 2021
l'objectif de ce report est de permettre
aux services de finaliser les
préparatifs en vue d'une application de
la réforme dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
vous l'aurez compris notre gros pour les
indépendants soutiendra l'adoption de ce
projet de loi merci l'état madame esther
benbassa pour cinq minutes pour le
groupe écologie solidarité territoire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la lenteur
mes chers collègues la france n'est pas
assez riche de ses enfants pour en
négliger un seul songé un instant à
cette phrase écrite dans le préambule de
l' ordonnance du 2 février 45
gardons là à l'esprit alors que nous
débattons aujourd'hui de ce projet de
réforme
à la lecture de ces mots il est
difficile de douter de la philosophie
initiale qui est claire elle résidait et
les idées derrière cette vision de la
justice pénale des mineurs
une justice spécifique qui vient au delà
de la sanction protéger aussi les
mineurs de même face à leur immaturité
la méconnaissance des nombreux pièges et
embûches de nos sociétés modernes ses
mots contre lesquels leur jeune âge ne
les prémunit pas toujours auquel même il
les expose
il s'agit ensuite d'une justice
bâtisseuse et non punitive
car elle repose sur le principe
fondateur de la primauté de l'éducatif
sur le répressif ayant qu'à prendre en
charge des personnes naturellement en
pleine construction
ce projet de réforme par ordonnance 40e
modification législative en la matière
cela est déjà été dit à plusieurs
reprises a été engagé par le
gouvernement en mars 2019 il se donnait
pour objectif de construire une justice
pénale des mineurs plus lisible et
efficace c'est top objective n'est
apparemment pas atteint les syndicats de
magistrats et les chefs de juridiction
vous avez talent
le thème sur le mini le délai avant
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
fin mars on mieux était bien trop court
pour permettre la mise en place de la
réforme dans de bonnes conditions
vous vous êtes prononcés positivement
pour le report du délai d'application au
30 septembre 1 22000 21 introduit par la
commission des lois dont acte
ce que jl non seulement met l'accent sur
le répressif mais aussi s'engouffre dans
le problématique rapprochement entre la
justice des mineurs est celle d'un
majeur à cet égard certaines
dispositions nous interpelle nous
demandons la suppression de l'article l
121-1 du code keeper qui prévoit une
exception à l'excusé de minorité
ainsi que celles de l'arctique elle 413
tirer un qui prévoient la retenue par un
officier de police judiciaire pour une
durée allant jusqu'à 12 heures
do mineur âgés de 10 à 13 ans le texte
gouvernemental ne prévoit qu'une
présomption simple à savoir que le juge
des enfants pour a à l'issue d'un débat
contradictoire déclare un animal de
moins de 13 ans responsable s'il a fait
preuve de discernement au moment des
faits ce qui est inacceptable
juridiquement c'est moralement la
présomption d'irresponsabilité
s'appliquant à ses enfants
nous proposons qu'elle soit il le flag
et que le seuil de 14 ans déjà appliquée
dans plusieurs pays européens soient
retenus en france
ajoutons que la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant de
l'onu prévoit un seuil
d'irresponsabilité pénale qui n'a jamais
été mis en place en france
enfin
nous refusons l'application du principe
de la surveillance électronique ou
bracelet électronique aux mineurs plutôt
que d'être coercitives la justice des
mineurs a surtout besoin de moyens
ce texte en soit il est jeune
loin de nous satisfaire nous tenteront
toutefois de l'amendé pour qu'une bonne
réforme de la justice pénale des mineurs
soit encore possible si nous n'y
parvenons pas nous voterons contre je
vous remercie madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux madame la
rapporteure mes chers collègues avant de
commencer mon propos je souhaiterais
apporter tout le soutien du groupe r d
se à notre collègue annie de billon dans
le traitement médiatique et sur les
réseaux sociaux ces derniers jours est
absolument injustifié et injustifiable
le texte dont elle est l'auteur
[Applaudissements]
le texte dont elle est l'auteure est une
avancée juridique incontestable nous
l'avons tous voter et les polémiques
regrettable ne nous empêcheront pas de
poursuivre avec elle notre travail pour
la protection des enfants
la tragédie de la petite eva elle 10 ans
lorsqu'elle a mis fin à ses jours après
avoir été harcelé par ses camarades ou
le lynchage du jeune écurie qui nous a
tous émus ces derniers jours résonne en
nous au moment de l'examen de ce projet
de loi
ces actes viennent nous rappeler que
l'enfant ce n'est pas toujours synonyme
d'insouciance et que les victimes même
si les coupables sont mineurs ont droit
à une réparation à cette nécessaire
réparation font écho nombre
d'interrogations sur le chemin que nous
voulons pour nos enfants et sans les
sanctions que nous devons apporter à
leur faute mais également la manière
d'éviter que certaines récidive et
plonge dans la délinquance
tant de questions qui auraient mérité un
débat plus long dans le temps et plus
large que la législation par ordonnance
ne permet que trop peu
hélas les interrogations que je
partageais à l'instant l'ordonnancé du 2
février 45 ya longtemps répondu les
principes cardinaux qu'elle pose de
spécialisation des juridictions de
recours à minima la privation de liberté
et d'atténuation de responsabilité par
rapport aux majeurs ne saurait être
contestées mais force est de constater
qu'au gré des réformes mais aussi d'une
société qui a évolué elle devait être
modifié et clarifier à ce titre
l'instauration d'une césure dans
l'objectif est de raccourcir les délais
entre le prononcé d'une peine et son
application est bienvenue
combien d'exemples avons-nous de jeunes
sanctionné après leur majorité au mieux
certains sont déjà sortis de la
délinquance au pire ils ont sombré
faute de mesure éducative prise assez
tôt pour être efficace ce système de
double l'audience l'une d'examen de
culpabilité votre de sanction devra
s'accompagner de moyenne et j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
concernant la procédure toujours je suis
plus partagés sur l'audience unique
bien que très encadrée ma crainte est de
voir cette procédure censée être un
outil d'exception se généralise
selon la directrice de la pjj ce sont
près de 20% des dossiers qui pourraient
être traités à mondial unique ce qui
viendrait mettre à mal le principe de
spécialisation des juridictions
pour en revenir à la sanction et à la
notion de discernement la fixation d'un
seuil s'apparente toujours un jeu
d'équilibriste temps un même âge peut
recouvrir des réalités et une maturité
différentes
la fixation à 13 ans de l'âge de
discernement nous permettra ici de
remplir nos obligations à l'égard de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant le fait que les présomptions de
discernement comme donnons discernement
ne soit pas irréfragable permettre
d'éviter des effets de seuil et laisse
toute latitude aux juges de lait
renversé si la situation l'exigé
concernant l'aspect sanction de ce code
de justice pénale des mineurs je
regrette que l'accent soit davantage mis
sur la privation de liberté que sur les
mesures éducatives les centres éducatifs
fermés sont une solution mais ils ne
peuvent être l'alpha et l'oméga de la
réponse juridique que nous apportons à
nos jeunes délinquants si beaucoup
d'entre eux sont très mobilisés sur les
mesures éducatives
ce n'est pas le cas partout monsieur
regard des souris nous faut garder à
l'esprit le principe du recours à minima
à la privation de liberté pour conclure
l'on peut écrire de bonnes lois mais si
la pratique est défaillante les forces
sera vaincu c'est pourquoi nous sommes
favorables à un report de l'entrée en
vigueur de ce texte le 30 septembre 2021
proposé par madame la rapporteure dont
je salue le travail et qui semble
beaucoup plus réaliste pour que ce texte
soit bien appliquée il faudra
inévitablement davantage de greffiers de
magistrats et donc davantage de moyens
pour la justice de notre pays
la récente hausse de 8 % du budget
global semble aller en ce sens mais ma
qualité de rapporteur du budget de la
pjj me rappelle que les budgets
consacrés à la formation de la pjj sont
en baisse de quoi susciter des
interrogations quant à la mise en place
de la réforme
pour conclure vous l'aurez compris
malgré toutes ces réserves
le groupe rdse dans sa majorité votera
ce texte mais gardera un oeil très
attentif sur sa mise en jeu
à l'avenir je vous remercie merci la
parole est maintenant pour monsieur
philippe bas pour 14 minutes pour le
groupe i république
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
président madame parent à porter mes
chers collègues je reprenais le texte
original de l' ordonnance de 1945 pour
préparer cette intervention
et puis j'y disais c'est dans le rapport
de présentation
il est signé du général de gaulle la
france n'est pas assez riche d'enfants
pour qu'on en perdre un seul
je crois qu'il est bon de garder cette
inspiration des auteurs de l' ordonnance
de 1945 dans une période si difficile la
situation de la délinquance des mineurs
restent inquiétantes en 2018
il y a eu des condamnations pour 9200
agressions dont 110 homicides et
blessures involontaires 200 viols 6400
cous et violences volontaires
il a eu 23 mille condamnation pour
atteinte aux biens et 5600 condamnation
pour trafic de stupéfiants
la part des mineurs dans la délinquance
pour autant semblent avoir diminué au
cours des 20 dernières années passant de
22 % à 18 % des mises en cause mais
elles demeurent les chiffres que je
viens de citer en atteste à un niveau
beaucoup trop élevé les principes de l'
ordonnance de 1945 notamment la primauté
de l'éducation sur la répression demeure
pertinent mais la pratique de la justice
des mineurs révèle des
dysfonctionnements importants et n'est
pas à la hauteur des ambitions de 1945
certes au fil des années de nouveaux
outils ont été introduits qui ont fait
la preuve de leur efficacité
c'est le cas par exemple des centres
éducatifs fermés
créée par le président jacques chirac et
son garde des sceaux à l'époque
dominique perben qui sont un réel succès
le crois qu'on peut le dire
seuls 10% des mineurs qui y sont
affectés sont finalement incarcéré
ce qui veut dire que 90% des autres
mineurs qui passe par les centres
éducatifs fermés sont remis qu'à un cas
sur un meilleur chemin cependant
l'insuffisance des places d'accueil est
réel et si la loi de programmation pour
la justice de 2018 a prévu l'ouverture
de 20 centres et 6
la chancellerie a engagé un travail
important pour permettre la construction
de ces centres seuls quatre d'entre eux
ouvriront d'ici à la fin du quinquennat
les travaux d'intérêt général également
des instruments qui n'existait pas en
1945 ils ont été introduit dans notre
droit
en 1983 il se sont développées seulement
au cours des années 90 ils ont été
réformés en 2014
mais il n'apporte pas les résultats
escomptés en 2019 4300 travaux d'intérêt
général ont été prononcées seulement
3200 ont fait l'objet d'un suivi par la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse est
actuellement il y à 13 mois d'attentes
quand un jeune est orienté vers un
travail d'intérêt général
c'est beaucoup trop long mais tous
gouvernements confondus
jusqu'à présent nous ne sommes pas
donner les moyens de nos ambitions
les jugements sont tardifs en cas de
poursuites
savez vous mes chers collègues qu'il
faut en moyenne 18 mois non 19
maintenant pour qu'une condamnation soit
prononcée
et comme souvent
les mineurs délinquants ont entre 16 et
18 ans il arrive fréquemment que les
condamnations sont prononcées quand le
mineur est devenu majeur
certains sont sortis de la délinquance
depuis longtemps quand ils doivent
purger leur peine
d'autres au contraire on tue le temps de
commettre de nombreuses récidives sans
avoir été arrêté par la moindre sanction
dans la dérive de la délinquance et les
derniers font l'école de la délinquance
dans détentions provisoires qui portent
mal leur nom puisque elles deviennent
interminable ces détentions provisoires
vont augmenter de 40% entre 2015 et 2019
ce qui donne une idée de la gravité de
la situation et du scandale de la
situation de la justice des mineurs dans
la période actuelle révisée 39 fois l'
ordonnance de 1945 est par ailleurs
devenu inaccessible aux magistrats aux
avocats aux avocats sauf les meilleurs
d'entre eux chez le ministre
bien sûr et encore plus aux délinquants
est alors victime
cette situation ne pouvait pas
s'éterniser et c'est pourquoi une
réforme était devenue indispensable
d'abord la codification alors évidemment
mes chers collègues il faut convenir que
notre valeur ajoutée en matière de
codification n'est pas aussi grande que
nous ne pourrions espérer et sur ce
point il faut reconnaître que le travail
de codification est tout destiné aux
ordonnances
nous sommes opposés contre les
ordonnances mais pas pour la
codification
nous sommes opposés aux ordonnances
parce qu'au delà de la nécessaire
codification nous avions à réformer le
régime de la justice des mineurs c'est
d'ailleurs ce que l' ordonnance a fait
et cette réforme des règles de la
justice des mineurs il me semble qu'elle
est présentée par la représentation
nationale dans le respect des principes
de 1945 et avec des innovations que nous
pourrons à prouver moyennant l'adoption
des amendements qui ont été adoptés par
la commission des lois sur la
proposition de notre excellente
rapporteur là ce sont des choix
politiques essentielles on peut les
approuver on peut les rejeter mais en
tout cas il convient que la
représentation nationale en dès l'hiver
et c'est pourquoi nous étions opposés à
l'habilitation nous sommes d'accord avec
le principe de la césure qui permettra
d'avoir un jugement sur la culpabilité
nous l'espérons dans le respect du délai
de trois mois qui est inscrit dans le
texte
nous sommes d'accord sur la mise à
l'épreuve éducative dans un délai de six
à neuf mois et sur le fait que le
jugement de sanctions quand il doit y
avoir un jugement de sanctions
interviennent au plus tard neuf mois
après le début de la procédure
nous sommes d'accord avec la
simplification des sanctions autour de
l'insertion de la réparation de la santé
du mineur et aussi en dernier recours du
placement et nous sommes d'accord
avec la simplification de l'organisation
renforçant le rôle du juge des enfants
je crois que nous pouvons également
qu'être d'accord avec la prévention de
la détention provisoire qu'elle ne soit
décidé qu'en cas de violations répétées
ou d'une particulière gravité des
obligations mises à la charge du mineur
notre commission des lois a cependant
souhaité trois types d'amélioration
elles ont été parfaitement présenté par
notre rapporteur la précision de la
notion de discernement du mineur qui ne
se réduit pas à la constatation de son
âge
la spécialisation des acteurs renforçant
encore le rôle du juge des enfants
c'est à lui de prononcer la détention
provisoire est à nulle autre avant
l'audience de culpabilité enfin nous
avons monsieur le garde des sceaux
considérez que vous aurez trop de mal à
tenir le délai que vous vous êtes
assignés à vous-même pour que nous ne
vous demandons pas de le prolonger
et c'est ainsi que la commission des
lois
vous la proposer je vois que vous êtes
d'accord sur le principe de prendre un
peu de temps parce que dans la période
que nous venons de vivre il y a eu
beaucoup d'instances qui n'ont pas été
traités
vous avez des problèmes matériels à
résoudre des problèmes de procédures des
problèmes d'informatique
je vois bien qu'un effort est fait pour
recruter des magistrats recruter des
greffiers rue recruter des éducateurs de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
mais enfin tout ceci ne peut pas donner
son plein effet en quelques semaines
et si cette réforme se mettent en oeuvre
alors que les conditions matérielles de
son application ne sont pas réunies elle
risque fort d'échouer c'est la raison
pour laquelle notre commission a insisté
sur la nécessité de se donner un peu de
marge
voilà monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le président madame le
rapporteur chers collègues ce que je
voulais vous dire en apportant le
soutien de mon groupe au travail
accompli par la commission des lois pour
améliorer une réforme dont les principes
nous paraissent conformes à ce que nous
pouvons attendre de la justice des
mineurs
[Musique]